what's happening there reject nation we
have ourselves the first episode of the
boys season three absolutely love this
series last time we covered the boys
with olivia but we are in the middle of
moving this week so next week you'll see
a completely different background hey i
just wanted to mention first real quick
it's the boys so you know like depending
on what level of graphic imagery
specifically with exposed body parts
we'll probably have to blur it because
we can't afford another community
guidelines trick right now uh just just
as a heads up youtube is not a fan of
that secondly if you want to watch the
full length watch along uh uncut you can
watch over our patreon page over there
we cover many shows with the same tier
you get the option for reaction
highlights and watch longs included for
some exclusive shows if you don't want
to do that please leave a like and your
comments down below and also subscribe
click that notification bell to get
notified when our next reaction for the
boys is up we're gonna try to play catch
up really fast before finally being
moved out of you lastly thanks to the
boys of prep for helping us add down
these highlights with a show like this
i'm sure you're gonna have a lot of fun
you know making sure to work around
certain moments but the real last thing
uh especially for something like the
boys uh where you're really likely to
not get monetization due to the content
that isn't it i want to thank
storyblocks for sponsoring this video uh
we've been hiring more people lately
like people at prepper and then you know
people like coy and i got sally coming
back on partnering up with people like
storyblocks really helps us keep
producing more content and expanding the
channel and doing stuff like the boys i
mean that sincerely so thank you sorry
blocks more on them right after the
reaction
before she was fried stormfront
i knew you'd be here who's playing
stormfront
[Music]
join me and we can reign together for a
thousand years
never
[Laughter]
our children could be
they would be the best of both of us
aryan kinderseldotten
no
they'd be monsters
like you
your choice leaption
but not even you could stop me alone
he's not alone
yeah
this movie actually seems pretty cool i
know i can't let you guys have all the
fun
they should just start spinning these
movies off because he's back in the
seven die winter mensch
oh they're at the premiere
it's not the stormfront you know seth
rogen utilized that charlize there in
connection to get her in here
[Music]
huey is attending the premiere
really whacked away that whole former
fugitive image huh
when are we gonna see you on the track
again
real soon but that race is coming full
speed ahead for the a train it's been
over a year in the people only questions
about the movie thank you so much
that's going to be a great interview
another big dick energy bro
i have no idea good
i didn't give a [__]
guys
pig
oh my god
everything we've been through we'd be
here
together
oh you sick bastard
what a photo op
i am just the man who fell for the wrong
woman um
[Laughter]
i found that little [__] we've been
on all month
don't meet the boys we're all set up we
just need you to uh
give us a green light no violence or
curb stomping or setting anyone on fire
okay expense reports you wanted good to
know he still works with him
amazon buying the kids some games
what
oh
my god
whoa
now this guy would go up thanos's
butthole
in a heartbeat
i want you inside me
oh he means literally oh yeah
let's go all greatest voyage in here
oh
man
boys will be boys
can't wait to have a herogasm
oh my god that's awesome
wow
[Music]
this
oh
[Music]
oh no i go
right
you can't leave
oh no
step on
oh god
get out
get
he's out to get in my ass
drop trail my god
yes
way to go butcher
[Music]
oh my god
got this orders
and put that little [__] on his side
wow
and we're back
here we are back
no questions
how surveillance goes with termite last
night you know i haven't checked in with
butcher yet but i'm sure it went fine
i'll bet you a crisp hundred dollar bill
something got [__] up you don't know
that i'll go take the bet
i'm i'm not gonna take the bet but
can i help you
i'm just waiting to see nadia that's
congresswoman victoria newman you're the
wrong person we're best friends
i will give her the message this way pal
you were the guy at the premiere
you gonna bring him that connect four i
thought he was fighting for the boys
i gotta do something to pass the time
oh
no he's happy to see him all right sweet
here you go
never guess what it is oh she watches
over oh that's great good for you malory
i hear you've been on the straight and
narrow all year we even follow hugh
campbell's orders without strangling him
now you're just being cruel
i know you're not doing all that for
yourself
so then who
the house
i need this equity
it's great to see you
did you just have a slot before me yeah
i'm just stumping for my book deeper
went awesome
deeper
how did you give this lot before me
it was a [__] up mistake that talent
booker is so [__] fired i'm asking
him i'm asking you i don't know
but it's
[__]
ridiculous
good to see you
too sir so despairing
it's the birthday girl
you're willing to have all this
superhero stuff yeah especially of the
seven homeland
i like the hair and then damn photos
photos
you know what
so um happy birthday ginny happy
birthday
you gotta move on marvin well you moved
on with todd or
i'm sorry
happy birthday to you
oh oh no you're a dork todd
you're a dork homelander
one dose of this temporary bee gives a
soldier 24 hours of powers give or take
and if it's temporary that means the dod
has to keep buying doses
and how much you hit
2 million oh my god
compound v is radio [__] active it's
not gonna fly in congress
i still have a few strings that i can
pull in congress
okay so she works with him
you and i built this place and we did it
the right way without being covered in
blood and guts
right so please just
trust me
but what about that guy that keeps
calling you nadia
tony we love tony
we're outmanned and outgunned and we've
got to put them [__] in a box before
they do it to us if you would just
compromise a little compromise
[__] you your whole life's a compromise
hey at least i have a [__] life oh
huey
it's okay to
stop to move on
she would have wanted you to oy
[__] wonder will you knock it off no
you have restored a wholesome
trustworthy image to the company when we
needed it the most which is why the
board
wants to make you co-captain of the
seven oh my god
your numbers are down what uh double
digits the public still associates you
with storm front this would be a real
bump oh my
god oh jesus
could you give us a moment look i really
like to keep discussing this absolutely
set a time with samantha and we'll get
you in
[Music]
real power
isn't this
it's the ability to bend the world to
your will
authority
to fill the team's empty slots
wow really
i am offering you
real
power real change
oh my god she can make it what she
dreamed of before all this happened that
was crazy
everything's looking up for everyone
this season
ain't nothing bad going to happen in any
of the ensuing episodes
literally thousands of tortured souls
who are trapped in that church right now
who want to escape just like me and my
wife did it's very brave thank you your
book deeper has been a game changer
oh my god
annie and i snuck into a cantina and
they had those i mean those yards of
margarita i must have drank a quarter
mile
shall we bring out starlight to do a
number and she just pukes in front of a
festival crowd
i had no idea you drank back then oh
yeah
miss kitty two shoes she had a fun side
big time
nice
tell me more
you've known him your whole life and you
know took your virginity so why would i
worry okay it was a mutual taking of
virginity's and you know what it
happened
so long ago and only a couple of times
and we weren't married so it felt weird
having sex
drummer boy didn't like to pound it you
know what i mean
sex drums
and i could make trouble at fought do
some real good or homelander could
murder you someone needs to stand up to
this guy and that has to be you not just
me i mean i could bring good people into
the seven who could help me wait you
mean like your boyfriend
no one even bats an eye when a man
climbs the lap okay you're right you're
right you're right look i'm i'm sorry
i'm sorry
see you later tonight
don't bother with the aquafresh i would
bring it just in case
oh my god he is just getting stripped
i feel like
homeland emasculated
god just the faces he's pulling this
episode or
what are you drinking
shake shack
oh
you want one i'll go grab a piece oh no
no thank you though
yeah
i see you got the extra whipped cream in
there no man he's judging him no no no
no
you know i need 30 000 calories a day
maybe when you actually ran you did
but now you're just eating your feelings
making us look ridiculous the fastest
man alive what a [__] joke
what did you say oh
oh
damn that's really well directed yeah
sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
ultimate eavesdropper
are we looking out for homelanders
victims they texted
butcher
today uh they made
starlight co-captain
my poor baby
i don't know how much more of this i
could take
no one suffers like you suffer
let me help you
honestly
i have to put up with these
no
month after month
they took myself from me
so pathetic oh my god i'm so pathetic
i think i have something
oh if we can find this
weapon or
whatever it is
maybe we can use it to blow homelanders
[__] brains out
here
holy crap she snatched it
this is our best chance to kill
homelander
don't [__] it up
it's only 24 hours
dad they've wasted no time in this
no i love it
may i come in
there there wasted no time
i love this i love it so much
can we just skip to the part where your
laser my [__] brains out where's the
sport in that you're like putting down a
wounded dog you're the one with your
tail between your legs and all the
[__] talk shows
[Laughter]
well what if we share a different
destiny
[Music]
only one of us left standing
isn't that what you want
too [__] right
i look forward to it
got this feeling in my buns
that's crazy that scene happened in the
first episode
[Music]
oh man
oh he's already like on top of it
nadia
hey nadia
[Music]
oh huey's gonna witness the wrong thing
hey tony
are you been oh [__] he's gonna witness
the wrong thing
we should tell everyone you have a
platform now we should tell everyone
about red river it's not that easy tony
tony i can't
please
[Music]
yep there it is
whoa
oh
good
[Music]
[Laughter]
you might as well obliterate his whole
face
and blow his whole yeah blow his whole
body up man
oh my god put him out of his misery
[Laughter]
i need a team
alleyway
east 12th and broadway
[Music]
crazy what a crazy good first episode
damn well done back with a bang what a
crazy good first episode yeah i was like
i first would probably have to take a
while to get it going and i was like oh
man they're like
full steam
that was great that was awesome well
yeah guys got a lot to say about this
one i can really feel it uh thank you
for sticking around before we jump into
our review a couple of quick words about
storyblocks thank you again for
sponsoring this video because uh
partnering up with you guys really helps
us out right now with everything we got
planned thank you to storyblocks for
sponsoring this video being the
cinematic artisans we obviously are we
are always in search of ways to make our
videos look better faster and most of
all for cheap cheap is good and if
you're a content creator or filmmaker or
anything in between you're probably in a
similar position it's tough to get your
content looking as good as it can be
without breaking the bank or burning
yourself out in the process which is why
i heavily encourage you guys to check
out what storyblocks has to offer cheap
is good do you feel like this is their
way of telling us that the videos could
be looking better yes whether it's the
credibility of an exotic establishing
shot the soothing comfort of the perfect
music bed or just the satisfaction of
increasing your graphical capability
storybox has an incredibly inclusive and
diverse library of faces places sounds
titles transitions filters and effects
and more over a million assets royalty
free and available for personal and
commercial use with your membership
sounds so affordable this is quite
affordable they have multiple
subscription levels to suit your exact
needs whether you're an independent
indie solo creator or a whole team so if
you want to learn more head on down to
our link in the description box and get
started that's at storyblocks.com
rejects now back to the video
all right well we don't have to talk for
too long because we've got more to get
to
but um yeah for a pilot i thought uh not
pilot for the first episode of season
three
a premiere i thought this was really
solid you know like season two
picked up pretty much right after
and this uh takes place
like since it wasn't right after but it
was a much smaller time span and this
one takes place uh i believe a year
after the events of season one and uh
season two i'm getting all my seasons
mixed up here and uh i really appreciate
just how full of force uh they went with
it just how gonzo it already is you know
like i remember when season two
premiered people felt like it was taking
a while to get going and there was
because they had they they switched from
instead of releasing them all at once
three at a time and then weekly and then
here i was like it's probably gonna be
the same thing you know like probably
the good stuff wouldn't happen until
episode three and wow they like the this
started off with what's that uh not
tremor tremor nah termite turmeric sorry
halfway uh termite at the very top was
mind blowing yeah like oh my god they
just they are showing that like and
they're supposed to be here orgasm this
season so i was like this is gonna be
that is what they're kicking off with i
can only imagine how far it's gonna go
and uh showing us where we are with our
characters um at this point in the story
of they're no longer fugitives they get
to have their own the the lives they
have now they're choosing to have these
lives you know um like huey gets to be
with starlight and work for uh newman
which is a fascinating setup because
he's got to be putting together that oh
my god i mean he didn't quite see what
happened yeah but he might be able to
piece together that exploding heads and
exploding from what happened last season
that must
maybe that was her this whole time
because we never got confirmation of who
that was that must be this person you
know it seems like he'd be sharp enough
to at least get on that scent or they at
least wonder it yeah because too i mean
she's calling teams to come clean this
up like he's gotta at least be suspect
of her in some degree yeah and the setup
too with stan edgar um it's it's cool
hopping back and forth between better
call saul and this where you got you
know giancarlo esposito playing two
head honcho bad guys who
run organizations that are on the front
look like something that's completely
completely different you know
and i i like seeing more of
his um
quandary that he's in here because he's
you get a better insight into how he
really feels towards the soups because
he always said he said at the beginning
of season two that
this isn't a superhero but this is a
pharmaceutical industry or something
like that that's that's the game they're
playing and as he uh brings that back in
this conversation and now that makes
more sense now it's clearer of the
direction that they really wanted to go
not just put soups in the military but
really control soldiers uh with this
comp this v24 thing that they have going
on but i love
i love the way his scenes are handled
because
when the doors are open it's a very
different personality you see it twice
in this episode the doors are open it's
the stan edgar that he puts on and then
when the doors are closed it's just like
i'm sick of this here's how i'm really
feeling yeah yeah
yeah
so you can get charming but not the
facade yeah you get to see a different
side to stan anchor here and um
so i appreciate the setup there this
whole thing with starlight that's going
to be really fascinating i feel like
maybe that jealousy thing will be the
thing that which is huey to get
like maybe i'll take the v24 you know
yeah it's gotta happen at some point
plus to see hughie take on whatever
powers he's gonna get like you know
what's gonna happen with butcher we've
seen a little bit of that in the
trailers but i'm excited to see i i can
imagine the whole team getting on at
some point yeah you know and really
getting to see the fun and games of that
i know in the comics they eventually all
do i believe but i
i mean i i don't know where the
direction of this show will go because
it's already so different in a lot of
ways
um because i like what they've done with
butcher you know i thought that with the
way season two ended that ryan would
just be kind of on off of his own and we
wouldn't really see him yeah and to know
that butcher still is like step dad or
surrogate father to him in some ways or
like i'm like uncle butcher in a lot of
ways um to this whole situation like
ryan running up to him and embracing him
with enthusiasm and butcher hugging him
back is something i wasn't expecting
that was a really heartfelt moment
because i thought he would still have
this like level of reprieve with him
where he doesn't want a connection
because of who he is
but to see that butcher is you know
willing to to be there for ryan and move
past the horrendous events and knowing
who you know ryan's truly the son of i
think was a really
uh really touching thing and and the
challenge of butcher having to
work with authority work with law be
governed
is
is interesting and they still keep it on
the the path
of yeah it's like it's always been his
journey is always something associated
with becca and now it's this disdain and
turmoil this rage that is working off of
off of the loss of becca
um
after all that's happened and now to be
in the position he's in now like to have
that scene with homeland or
just
it's something so surprising because you
don't really get a lot of homelander and
butcher together even though butcher's
always that's the bullseye for him
that's the target and then so to start
your season off with us with a really
tense taught scene at the top of this at
the very end of this episode of
foreshadowing a a
a feeling of what their final showdown
might be like
uh was
very fascinating and very compelling and
[Music]
yeah the trailer gave away like the
first thing in the trailers giveaways
that he's going to take the v24 yeah
that's the first thing so yeah um but
yeah how are you feeling about
homelander and all that i love that i
love that a lot and i thought that
on top of everything they built
prior in the episode itself you know
everything we see with butcher
everything we see with homelander i
thought it was a really
beautifully twisted
yeah character beat emotional moment to
have it be that in a way i swear it
looks like homelanders like even though
he's not really opening up to butcher
he's like the one person it's the one
exchange where it feels like they're on
sort of a level of some kind and he's
identifying and i think that's a really
cool note for both those characters
because as much as they hate each other
and represent the sort of polar
opposites in a way they also kind of are
at this stage in time the only people
who can kind of understand what each
other is sort of dealing with which i
think is is beautiful in a show that
gets you know obviously twisted in terms
of its action and in terms of its
various pulpy elements uh you know that
is something really harsh and nasty but
also
like touching in a in a dark way yeah
and i appreciated that uh very much and
this was a an episode in an entirety
that
it's like last season we were sitting
there going yeah i see why they released
three episodes because they're like now
it feels kind of like we're at the start
whereas here i was like i could wait a
week for the next one and be totally
satisfied with this as the premiere
which i think is great which i think is
really strong and i think they're doing
a nice job of yeah
really laying down the place of here's
where everybody is a year later you know
here are some shifted power dynamics
here are some people who are estranged
and it felt like everybody got just
enough time to really feel like the
ensemble is back and reestablished and
we know where all the pieces are but
we're also pretty connected like i
thought pretty much every plot line was
pretty engaging and pretty engrossing
and i love just the sick and twisted
web of influence and tension that there
is with homelander and everybody under
homelander and everybody who's now above
homeland yeah on the food chain and uh
yeah i mean i'm i'm very curious to see
how that interplay uh goes down with vot
and the newman campaign because
obviously they are connected obviously
they are playing ball and the trailers
do give away that thing too of huey
being like well you know i try to do it
the legit way it's not working but uh
you know i wonder what commentary is
gonna arise from that too because you
know that's obviously a big part of i
heard a great little uh take on this
that like the comics of the boys go so
far as to um
deconstruct and comment on superhero
comics whereas the show is about
superhero
visual media shows and movies uh more so
i said that in the last trailer reaction
oh is that what you said yeah oh great
well then i
you never heard it from anybody else
i don't know i don't think so then i
stole it from you that's even better
that's pretty sure
it might just be a common opinion i
don't know i mean yeah i i it seemed
said with authority and it seemed also
like something that i think is very
evident when you look at them and you
look at them side by side did i take it
from someone
i don't know i don't think so i don't
think it's a takeable i don't i don't
think it's a point where it's like uh
you stole that it's more like i remember
when i said that i was like i think i
just came up with an interesting point
then you probably did it but i'm pretty
sure now i'm like but i probably took
that from someone else no i mean hey in
in in week to week time watch a lot of
stuff must have taken it from someone
else i don't think so i'm pretty sure i
did i think something in my back of
mine's like no i think i took that from
someone else even if you did
even if you arrived at it independently
or not it's very good
i appreciate it
you know
we'll go back pretty sure it's been a
common opinion
so i you know you see so many things in
a week sometimes things blur together as
to where
but anyhow i i feel like they do a
really great job of deconstructing that
stuff but they also do happy rockstar
said it
okay that sounds
sounds reasonable too
[Laughter]
i mean it's a good point
overall and nobody always care about
giving proper credit you know
scared about even proper credit if i've
heard it from someone i think it was
them or heavy spoilers maybe i'm not
sure all right what does it matter
continue i heard it from you
and then the rest is up to you to figure
out but either way uh yeah that that
being that this is the more sort of
cinematic uh breakdown of superheroes
and whatnot uh i feel like too there
could probably be because this is being
made at a slightly different time be
some interesting updates on the you know
the conversations surrounding money
power politics and etc
um and i feel like the show generally
does a nice job at incorporating all
that stuff and i am excited to see how
that grows here too well it seems like
with homelander that is going to be
uh you know buddying up with the storm
chasers who are representing uh you know
an alt-right section of the world yep um
i'm not sorry that's what the show's
doing okay so yeah
so yeah like that's what uh that's it's
that's because homelander always goes
where he feels loved and accepted that's
where he gravitates towards
always and so
i'm sure he's gonna find the catharsis
uh with that group even though he's like
no none of this aryan stuff
which which is you know maybe not what
that group is directly saying
um
however they are going to be the
representative factor even budding up
with this i forget the guy's name but
the one who resembles tucker carlson oh
yeah yeah
the deep navin has come back slowly
deeper i think it's a funny ass title
uh a train struggling with a weight loss
issues
that's i think there's some really great
directed moments you know like i like
the when he whispers [__] you and the
way they kept it in one shot like you
got to have like really good timing
because as actors anthony starr anthony
starr has to be like
he probably couldn't actually hear him
yeah
you know
and so he had to somehow be cute or had
to be so timed
to the point where he could hear him i
don't know how they did that yeah or
even the way they showed with mother's
milk uh marvin when they
when and when uh it looks like oh he's
got his whole family together he's got
his wife back where she always you know
last season was like i'm leaving you i'm
leaving you you know this is enough you
keep saying you're dumb you're back in
and you lied to me
than to have the todd guy come in and
you're like oh that's a good visual way
of just showing us you know so i thought
there were some really just great
directed moments and
i mean the way that he opened up the
closet was like is his butcher going in
there and planting [__] yeah like look
what we got more is he just doing is i
imagine he just he just can't truly let
it go yeah yeah and then the question
becomes yeah is he doing this in
coordination with butcher or just he
just knows what needs to be done and
he's already doing the leg work yeah
yeah but this was an amazing first
episode loved it we gotta hop on to the
next one guys uh leave your thoughts
down below what did you think about this
pilot and also you know gimmick
i like that because she's a mute and
then she you know she lives in the
music the musical mind that's a cool way
to express
uh how she's really feeling
and so more piano more piano so yeah i
really think this is all great stuff and
uh subscribe click that bell keep a look
out for our next reaction
we'll see you guys soon
[Music]
you